Can a mustache kill a movie? You betcha:
just ask Henry Cavill and Joss Whedon.
This is the story of Superman's brush with
infamy — and the fallout that followed.
Kal-El, the Last Son of Krypton, famously
gains his powers from exposure to Earth's
sun. Aside from a slew of abilities
that includes flight, super speed,
and x-ray vision, one thing that puts the
Man in Tights in a league of his own is his
invulnerability. After all, he's not called
the Man of Steel for nothing. Naturally,
then, a standard razor should stand no
chance of clipping Clark Kent's facial
hair to the baby-faced cleanliness that has
become standard for the fictional character.
The uncertainty around Kal-El's shaving technique
became the theme of an ad campaign from Gillette
in 2013. Corresponding with the release of
Henry Cavill's premiere outing as Superman,
Man of Steel, the company went all out in an
attempt to answer this comic book riddle. The
company assembled a Justice League-level group of
nerds to present differing theories, from director
Kevin Smith to Bill Nye, and fans were asked to
make a vote for their favorite theory online.
"Other people have suggested a Kryptonite razor,
as if that's simple. Would you shave with
death, ladies and gentlemen? Of course not."
However, Gilette must have
missed the episode of Superman:
The Animated Series in which Clark Kent gets
that perfect smooth trim using a mirror and
his powerful heat vision — two products
that the company sadly doesn't sell.
Since the first comic book appearance
of Superman in 1938's Action Comics #1,
the clean chin and upper lip have
been a staple for the character's
visage. Although he has disguised
himself many times over the years,
the clean cut look is as much a part of
Supes' costume as the "S" on his chest.
Clark Kent does have the
ability to grow facial hair,
though. Superman #139 features an
entire storyline around the effects
of Red Kryptonite weakening Kal-El's powerful
vision, resulting in his hair and fingernails
growing far more than is appropriate
for Kent's day job at the Daily Planet.
So it's not that Superman can't grow a
sweet 'stache, but rather that audiences
change their opinion regarding the true-blue
hero when he sports facial hair. Generally,
Superman donning a beard insinuates that the
bald-faced crimefighter has been absent for
a period or aged considerably. As seen in
Superman III, something as insignificant
as five o'clock shadow can even make Superman
look like an evil version of himself. Meanwhile,
the clean cut helps to fortify Clark Kent as the
responsible Boy Scout he traditionally represents.
While Henry Cavill has been limited to filming
less than a minute of screen time as Superman
in the last five years, the actor's early days in
the blue tights were highly productive. Making his
debut in 2013's Man of Steel solo flick, Cavill
continued his time in the spotlight with Batman
v Superman: Dawn of Justice in 2016. Powering
through that movie's poor critical reception,
production for Cavill's next adventure as Supes
began less than a month later. Unfortunately,
unbeknownst to everyone involved
during those first days of filming,
Justice League was about
to unravel the entire DCEU.
"Boo yah."
At the conclusion of Batman v Superman, Supes is
defeated by the monstrous Doomsday, and the first
half of Justice League is built around the rest
of the team bringing him back to life. As such,
the Man of Steel's screen time is limited compared
to his superpowered colleagues. Notably, though,
even after being raised from the dead, Superman
maintains his babyface trim. Presumably,
every scene that Cavill shot for Justice
League during principal photography,
which wrapped in October 2016,
featured a clean-cut Clark Kent.
The process of bringing Justice League to life
was tumultuous to say the least. Originally,
Warner Bros. had struggled to get the
movie going after first announcing a
pre-DCEU version in 2007. As production
finally loomed in 2016, Zack Snyder's
original proposal of a two-part film was
nixed by the studio. Even during filming,
the backlash to the critically panned Batman v
Superman resulted in substantial rewrites and
changes in producers. Still, the most significant
hit to the film occurred in post-production,
when Zack Snyder left the project due
to the sudden death of his daughter.
After attempting to return to work,
Snyder opted to completely step away
from Justice League. In his announcement, he said:
"In my mind, I thought it was a cathartic
thing to go back to work, to just bury
myself and see if that was the way through it.
The demands of this job are pretty intense. It
is all-consuming. And in the last two months,
I've come to the realization; I've decided to
take a step back from the movie to be with my
family, be with my kids, who really need me."
As principal photography on Justice
League seemed to come to an end,
the cast dispersed into other projects.
Henry Cavill moved into production on the
action thriller Night Hunter, which failed
to garner much positive attention. However,
it is notable for one particular reason: Cavill
had grown a scruffy beard for the project. So,
when the actor shifted to his next film, Mission:
Impossible – Fallout, the choice was made to give
his character a mustache. Fallout director
Christopher McQuarrie later told the AV Club:
"Henry just finished [Night Hunter] and had
a big beard and the mustache and long hair.
When he came to work, he had cut his hair but
still had that mustache and he asked, 'What do
you think?' I thought about it for a second
and said, 'You know what, let's go for it.'"
Unfortunately, this off-hand decision would
later lead to significant problems when
Cavill received a call to return
for reshoots on Justice League,
three months into filming on
Mission: Impossible — Fallout.
In the wake of Zack Snyder's departure from
Justice League, Warner Bros. and DC enlisted Joss
Whedon to take over, who had previously helmed
Marvel's The Avengers and Avengers: Age of Ultron.
"Avengers…"
With yet another creative mind now
embedded in the Justice League scuffles,
the studio agreed to two months and $25
million worth of reshoots — a significant
cost compared to the standard reshoot budget of
$6 million to $10 million and a couple of weeks.
Aside from scheduling conflicts with the movie's
stars, the studio had its own demands for the
reshoots that would add to this growing monster of
a film. First, the theatrical version was limited
to a two-hour runtime, a demand made by Warner
Bros. CEO Kevin Tsujihara. More challenging,
the release date of the movie was
kept in its tight November 2017 spot,
despite these multiple obstacles. Warner
Bros. executives refused to consider any
delays out of a fear of losing potential financial
bonuses ahead of an upcoming merger with AT&T.
The problem of Henry Cavill's mustache served to
distract from all the other drama surrounding the
Justice League reshoots. The price tag Warner
Bros. faced for Justice League was approaching
$300 million with the added reshoot fund;
meanwhile, Paramount's Mission: Impossible
– Fallout came in at an equally impressive $250
million. Obviously, neither studio wanted to face
the risk of a continuity error, deal with the CGI
removal of Cavill's facial hair, or worst of all,
have the actor wear a fake mustache. As
Christopher McQuarrie told the AV Club:
"I've worked with fake mustaches before.
You can get away with it for a shot or two,
but it doesn't work over the course of a movie."
Surprisingly, though, the director was open to
compromise. The Fallout crew tallied the number
of shots in which Cavill featured, and worked
out how much those shots would cost to reshoot:
$3 million. McQuarrie then suggested that he shut
down production on the movie while Cavill grew his
mustache back, while Warner Bros. simply would
pay Paramount for the loss. Paramount, however,
refused to let McQuarrie do this. Because he was
under contract, Cavill was forced to keep his
thick mustache during the Justice League reshoots.
In an unpleasant twist of fate, Fallout ended up
having to shut down production anyways after
lead actor Tom Cruise broke his ankle on set.
As the dust settled on the studio war,
the task of disguising Cavill's mustache
landed in the laps of visual effects
artists — and it didn't turn out well.
"You won't let me live. You won't let me die."
The first leaked images of the cropped
mustache quickly took over the internet
to heavy mockery. In the aftermath,
an anonymous visual effects artist for
DC opened up in a Reddit AMA that
has since been archived. Notably,
the unnamed VFX crewmate passed the blame for at
least one particularly terrible shot. They said:
"I'm not sure which other studio did that opening
shot on the cell phone but it's dreadful. It
shouldn't have been approved internally let
alone gone all the way to make it into the film."
Perhaps inevitably, Henry Cavill's botched lip job
became one of the hottest topics
on social media. Cavill himself,
however, enjoyed the process of becoming the
internet's favorite joke. He told Yahoo.com:
"I sure wasn't expecting that to happen. I love
that it has. It's cool. I can
show my grandkids one day."
It didn't take long for Cavill to
stoke the flames of the meme sensation,
either. The actor took to his own
social media, sharing a picture of
a strange-looking contraption from the set of
Mission: Impossible — Fallout. The caption read:
"Pictured above [...] is in fact the latest in
a series of weapons being designed by Warner
Bros and Paramount Studios to combat the entity
known as "Henry Cavill's Moustache." [...] It
is not a question of IF I should shave —
it is a question of how can we possibly
be victorious against such a beast without
bringing our own doom raining down upon us."
Sadly, Cavill later bade farewell to his
furry friend in a heartfelt Instagram post
that featured a long mustache montage backed
by Sarah McLachlan's "I Will Remember You."
"I can tell you this though,
I will remember him. Always."
The drama behind Justice League caught
up with the film upon its release. The
movie officially premiered in November 2017,
pulling in $96 million from the domestic box
office on opening weekend — short of the
$110 million the studio had projected.
The lowest opening of any DCEU project at
that point, part of the failure was down
to theatrical competition from Thor: Ragnarok
and Coco. It certainly didn't help, though,
that the backstage confusion behind Justice League
translated so obviously onto the big screen.
Meanwhile, fans were anything but impressed that
Superman was absent from the majority of Justice
League's theatrical cut, an issue made worse
by the movie's strange pacing. Worse still,
Cavill's uncanny CG face had apparently gone
unfixed for the cinematic debut, leading to
even more insults regarding sloppy VFX. Fans
weren't sure what to expect from Justice League
after the disappointment of Batman v Superman
and the surprise success of Wonder Woman. Sadly,
with this movie, all of the DCEU's myriad
of problems seemed to come together at once.
In an unprecedented maneuver from Warner Bros.,
the studio gave Zack Snyder another chance to
finish his vision of Justice League. Folding to
a massive social media campaign calling on DC
to "Release the Snyder Cut," WarnerMedia
subsidiary, HBO Max, handed the director
$70 million to rebuild the film utilizing the
photography that he had already completed. With
a unique post-production process taking place
during the Covid-19 pandemic, the restructured
4-hour Zack Snyder's Justice League was released
exclusively on the streaming platform in 2021.
Snyder pulled no punches discussing
the theatrical release of the film,
which he claims he has never watched.
At a Comic-Con event, he said:
"I would destroy the movie,
I would set it on fire before I would use
a single frame that I did not photograph."
And as for the infamous Superman 'stache?
"It's sad to think that that would have been the
last view that people had
of Superman was just that."